Amber Heard and Johnny Depp's legal  battle rages on the 30 year old Justice  League actress and the fantastic beast  star have been going back and forth over  finalizing their divorce for months now  just when we thought things were  wrapping up Johnny's attorney Laura  Wasser filed Doc's  asking amber to pay $100,000 toward the  actors attorneys fees and amber isn't  having it believe it or not on Friday  her legal team fired back filing  documents of their own in which amber  states  Johnny wishes to quote prolong this  proceeding as means of punishing me and  went on to say I want my life back I  want to be divorced from Johnny now the  former pair met while on set of the film  The Rum Diary in 2011 and were married  for just over a year  [Music]